how have you guys changed and evolved in
terms of your approach to music in the
last like 15 years we wake up and and
decide you know today we're just gonna
write something that's from the heart so
in in that way that really hasn't
changed over the years but you know a
lots a lots changed obviously Matt's
part of the family it's been been over
five years now
Matt Walt joined his brother Brad and
three days grace after their original
lead singer Adam Gontier abruptly left
in 2013 just weeks before a tour to
pursue other interests do you still hear
from them do you guys have relationship
no he's kind of gone in his old
direction and we had kind of gone in one
direction and have maintained that for
us we just push like in direction we're
going the sound that we have now and and
we don't really look back in any way
yeah and you guys this new album
outsider but what does that mean you
know outsider is really kind of I think
you know a common thread that goes
through the album of just sort of being
tired of being so close to so much
sensory overload and just information
and and like just overload of emotions
you guys have achieved so much over the
last yeah like 15 years of your career
as a band together what do you want to
achieve in 2018 we're just gonna tour a
lot and just we love playing live so hmm
I can't wait to get on a bus with these
guys but it never gets a little it gets
no you know it's we're lucky we we you
know we get along we're a team and stuff
well thank you for your time guys an
absolute pleasure to meet you thank you